hey youtubers is Charlie happy Friday so
Ryan Reynolds just confirmed that
they've finished filming the Deadpool
movie so I thought it was time to do new
bonus video this is gonna be some of
Deadpool's biggest female characters
there are a whole bunch of women that
he's run into in big story lines like
Black Widow for instance but these are
mostly gonna be x-men based characters
just you know people that the movies
could actually have a chance of doing
you have to remember that Deadpool is
part of the x-men universe he's not part
of the Marvel Universe so until they
reach some sort of like spider-man
arrangement don't expect to see any
Deadpool in the Marvel Universe first up
is dr. Betty aka dr. hotness she was a
doctor that worked for aim that was
trying to infiltrate Hydra on a mission
to the Savage Land to recover the zombie
head of Deadpool she debuted in Merc
with the mouth number one which is
actually just one of the best Deadpool
storylines ever so it's actually good to
read if you haven't checked it out yet
Hydra was trying to find the zombie head
to turn it into a weapon like it still
carried the zombie virus Betty got stuck
in the Savage Land
so Deadpool was hired to go in and get
her so it became this big deadpool vs
dinosaurs situation which you know which
is awesome i feel like the best 10 pool
stories are the most ridiculous ones
mixed up this copycat aka Vanessa
Carlysle this is the character that
Morena Baccarin is playing in the movie
which is funny because she's also a cast
regular on season 2 of Gotham this year
so she's dumping back and forth between
DC and the x-men universe her version of
the character is probably gonna be
vastly different than what's in the
comics just because copycat is so nuts
she became so obsessed with him that she
would shape-shift into the form of other
women that he was dating the first time
she appeared was in New Mutants number
98 and in that issue she was also
pretending to be Domino who was in a
sexual relationship with cable so you
can see how the movie might sidestep
some of that craziness her ability that
works a lot like Mystique's only it goes
way beyond that she has the ability to
perfectly mimic other people's powers
which mystique can't do it is rumored
though that she's Mystique's daughter
which would make her Nightcrawler sister
most of the time when she showed up
she's been an x-force or a new mutants
character but she did have a really
minor part in Marvel Civil War event
she's just a character that gets really
tied up in the origin story of deadpool
himself so she's gonna be a big part of
the movie most likely as that pulls a
life because as crazy she sounds she
still loves him but
she knew him before he became Deadpool
and after next up is a fun one the
personification of death she and
Deadpool there's really funny romance
that they kind of started during the
Deadpool death annual in 1998
Deadpool just started to fall in love
with her because he had so many
near-death experiences she also started
fall for him too so he started to look
for ways to join her so that his spirit
could live with her forever
but Thanos who's historically been
obsessed with death got super jealous
because she preferred Deadpool over him
so he cursed Deadpool with immortality
so that they could never truly be
together that happened during Deadpool
vol 2 number 61 in terms of level of
ridiculousness this is you know closer
to the top of the pile in terms of
Deadpool stories just because the idea
of the personification of death falling
in love with a regular character just as
hilarious if death is gonna fall in love
with someone
of course Deadpool is gonna be really
high on the list along with Adam warlock
and Thanos the tone that that takes
whatever it's told from Thanos
perspective like during the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline is is way more
serious though the Deadpool version is
like the ridiculous addition of that up
next is anaconda whose real name is
actually Blanche she's actually one of
the few characters that Deadpool's
admitted to being afraid of they met for
the first time in cable and Deadpool
number nine she's like another mercenary
with superhuman abilities that was
trained by taskmaster but she's been a
member of six pack along with a couple
other deadpool female characters then
there's x-force and serpent society she
actually she started out as just like a
normal steel worker for Roxon I mean
she's like a pretty big girl to begin
with but they recruited her to become a
secret agent laced her body with
adamantium and then gave her some some
extra genetic enhancements they kind of
made her look a little bit like a snake
in the context to the movies you can
think of hers being like like a version
of Lady Deathstrike from the second
x-men film that version was like a
dramatic change from the Lady
Deathstrike of the comics but but you
get the idea she had the ability to
elongate certain parts of her body she
was like super bendy super flexible
super strong next up is Domino aka Nina
Thurmond she's into the character that's
had like run ins with copycat in really
funny ways but she's a former member of
x-men and a longtime lover of cables she
debuted in New Mutants number 98 the
same issue that copycat debuted but
whenever Domino showed up for the first
time she was actually secretly
copycat it was like an imposter Domino
her powers not knock copycats but
Domino's are kind of a spin on scarlet
witch's you know - the chaos magic she
has the ability to affect probability
she's like a way less powerful version
of Scarlet Witch though she mostly works
as a mercenary so she's highly skilled
with guns she is a mutant but she got
her powers as the result of a government
genetic breeding program she wasn't like
one of the x-men that pop up just
because of random genetic chance in
addition to x-men though she's also been
a member of x-force and six pack you get
the idea you know a lot of Deadpool
characters are also x-force characters
just because Deadpool was in those
comics for a long time
next up is outlaw aka an Dez temple she
was naturally born a mutant but her her
only real ability is enhanced strength
later though she became a master
marksman so she's mostly a mercenary
they just also has super strength she
and Deadpool had this really fun
adventure when they were hired to steal
Punishers cult 45s it was an epic fail
Punisher ended up locking them in a
phone booth naked but she did develop a
relationship with Deadpool so they did
have a lot of fun sexy time she's
another one of those x-men universe
characters that showed up during
Marvel's civil war so don't don't expect
her to show up in any of the Marvel
films especially Captain America Civil
War she would be like a light version of
Black Widow just because they do a lot
of the same things even though Black
Widow doesn't have super-strength the
fun twist on that you know because Black
Widow had a big thing with Hulk and in
age of Ultron is that it nez actually
Hulk's out a little bit gets like a
little crazy when people call her by her
nickname which is crazy and nez she
picks it up as a child absolutely hates
it so anytime anyone calls her that she
just flips her [ __ ] she debuted in
deadpool number 65 she was actually
created by gail simone but suicide kings
is another cool storyline if you want to
read more about her
and finally less big one the evil queen
of the Dead aka mrs. Deadpool Shukla was
the catalyst of the wedding of Deadpool
storyline recently Dracula hires
Deadpool to escort his new bride to
their wedding he's going to have this
political marriage that's going to unite
a lot of factions she herself was it was
a pretty terrible person you know
getting married to another terrible
person Dracula a rival group of vampires
tried to kill her enroute Deadpool saves
her in the course of events she gets out
she and Deadpool go on the run because
so many people are after them including
Hydra they developed something of a
relation
when they finally escape everyone they
go back to New York and have a wedding
officiated by Nightcrawler attended by a
bunch of other big characters you
remember she's the Evil Queen to the
dead so like the first time Deadpool
helps her out like does something nice
for her she actually tries to steal his
life force by kissing him so she's
certified evil even even though she
becomes something of a sympathetic
character in this storyline that was in
the gauntlet infinity so I'd actually I
recommend you check that out that
happened pretty recently so they're like
a whole bunch of other female characters
the Deadpool gets involved but you're
like Elektra who's gonna be in daredevil
season two as well as saira another
x-men character but let me know what is
your favorite female Deadpool character
I'm sure some of you are like raising
your hands and saying Lady Deadpool
who's like an alternate universe version
of Deadpool I don't even want to think
about what that relationship would look
like the funny thing about the women
that Deadpool runs into is you know
either they end up in actual
relationships like they either end up
hooking up or he just ends up flirting
really awkwardly with them I mean he's
the Merc with the mouth so you can't
expect him to not hit on anything that
moves the movie itself like the Deadpool
movie is gonna be a little more subdued
you know just because they're not
spending like 150 million dollars on it
like they would an Avengers or a giant
x-men film but do expect a lot of minor
characters to show up because it is an
x-men crossover film like it's part of
the x-men universe officially I wouldn't
be surprised if a few minor x-men
characters showed up but nobody's been
confirmed Ryan Reynolds has been really
good about about posting stuff from the
set so if there's any other Deadpool
videos that you guys want from the
comics or you know just about the movie
leave your requests in the comments and
be sure to subscribe to get everything
this summer's gonna be a lot of fun I'm
doing a lot more movie videos this
summer speaking of which if you guys
haven't seen it I just did a big Suicide
Squad video you can click here to watch
that and you can click here to learn all
about the new guardians of the galaxy TV
series it's a new animated series that's
coming later this summer thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tomorrow
you